you
some of the greatest works of art are
just beneath the waves standing in just
25 feet of water off the coast of Cancun
Mexico
the Masayo sub aquatic eau de Arte is
both a monument to human creativity and
the natural beauty of the caribbean reef
ecosystem the museum is a vast
collection of underwater galleries with
over 500 sculptures many focused on
themes of human interaction and impact
on the environment the Marine Park where
the museum is located is one of the most
visited stretches of water in the world
with nearly 800,000 visitors each year
immense pressure is placed on the native
reef ecosystem that's why every
sculpture is made from cement suitable
for the growth of coral seaweed and
algae the many holes in the sculptures
make perfect homes from marine wildlife
to colonize and feed off the coral the
hope is that as nature continues to
colonize these statues they will
transform into massive reefs
unrecognizable for what they once were
and it's also attractive to humans it
has become one of the most popular dive
locations in the area hopefully
signaling a more prosperous relationship
between man and nature
Oh
[Music]